what if you could release a feature to
different groups of users
without deployment is there a way to
effectively test features
in production and immediately roll them
back if needed
hi my name is dylan arena with ibm cloud
i'll be answering those questions by
discussing feature flags
or sometimes referred to as feature
toggle or switches
feature flags are conditions that
encompass feature code
that allow you to flip them on and off
at will
okay let's use an example let's say
we've got an ice cream shop franchise
that's looking to expand to a new city
and we've got a banner that we want to
display
on our website
we'll call this open banner
we only want to display this banner
to users that are nearby
our new ice cream shop we can do this
by using feature flags there's a couple
benefits to using feature flags
number one is we can actually turn these
on or off without deployment
number two is we can actually
test directly in production
and number three we can segment our
users
based on different attributes
okay there's a couple ways you can do
this
one way is by using properties in json
files or config maps
there's a better way however by using a
feature flag service
there's a couple benefits to using a
feature flag service number one
is you can have essentially managed
place
for your features or excuse me your
feature flags
number two is you can turn these on and
off
without modifying
your properties in your future in your
apps or web pages
and number three is you get audit and
usage data
it's harder to get the audit and usage
data by using json files
okay so now let's go back to our example
we've got our open banner
feature and now let's wrap it with some
feature flag code
and so here's an example kind of pseudo
code that you can use
if store open
is enabled
then we're going to show
open banner
so this pseudocode represents our
feature code
and the flag that potentially could
encompass it
now let's actually put this in
production
and make it show
showcase to some users so
now that we've got our feature in
production it's not usable to any users
right now
this is an idea typically displayed with
feature flags called dark launch
dark launch is when a feature is in
production but not visible to any
or all users or any or some users excuse
me
now we want to introduce the idea of
segments
so we've already said that we only want
a certain number of people to view this
people who are nearby our new shop this
will be our segment a
and a segment is simply users or groups
of users
that have attributes to tied to them so
this first one might have
current location
and zip code
attributes this allows users who are
either currently in the location
or have already stipulated that they
live nearby to view
this feature but before we do that
we want to test the feature out
on our own employees so we would have
segment b
of our testers because we want them to
be our employees
the attribute might be email id
now we can effectively test our feature
in production by flipping this toggle on
so now this feature is on for our
testers and say maybe something went
wrong
so we're actually going to flip it off
fix it and then we'll turn it back on
for segment b
once we're satisfied that everything is
working well then we can flip this on
for our segment a now all this is done
without a deployment because our feature
is already in production all
we're doing is making it visible or not
visible to certain users
once it is in production we can actually
add a little bit of automation to this
with our testers we did it manually we
flipped it on and off manually
but with feature flags we can actually
add a time element so let's say we only
want this to be viewable for
three weeks two weeks before grand
opening one week after grand opening of
our new shop
this will be flipped on and then
automatically turned off or not visible
for this segment of users after three
weeks
okay so now we're getting really good at
using feature flags
so our feature flags are potentially
starting to stack up
we might have a couple apps and a couple
websites with a couple different types
of features
that are flagged so we've got maybe app
one here app two
and say a web page
with a feature plugging service we can
actually group these in collections
so that we're a little bit more
organized with which feature flags are
tied
to which apps are web pages so now today
we've learned about returning feature
flags on and off without deployment
testing directly in production and then
segmenting those features
based on the user attributes thank you
for watching if you have questions
please drop us a line below if you want
to see more videos like this in the
future
please like and subscribe and don't
forget you can grow your skills and earn
badges
with ibm cloud labs which are free
browser-based
interactive kubernetes labs